gut dann begrüßte sie zur heutigen
sitzung in der wir uns diesmal einen
neueren philosophen vorgeknöpft haben
nämlich diesen herren mit dieser schönen
pfeife und heißt wird schon größer und
ich glaube meine geburtsdaten dichter
angegeben haben sind diesmal richtig
also sehr alt geworden 98 jahre
es muss aber 1872 als wäre er praktisch
- zwei jahre alt geworden das ist auch
lässt sich nicht also muss natürlich
1872 heißen und diesen aufsatz den hatte
also im alter von 40 jahren
veröffentlicht und das schließen sie aus
diesem bild wenn sie diesen herren hier
sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut ganz genau
also daraus können sie schließen er
kommt nicht aus den usa
woher kommt er dann aus england ist doch
klar
also und als diese haltung mit der hier
diese teil verhebt diese haltung die
manifestiert er auch mit seiner
philosophie also auch im stil seiner
philosophie behaupte ich jetzt mal und
jetzt wollen wir uns mal ein paar
leitfragen überlegen als er hatte
natürlich diesen aufsatz in motion auf
kurs hat er geschrieben in einer
zeitschrift in
ich glaube der ist italiens seit je das
ist so ein recht bekannte zeitschrift
und dieser aufsatz ist recht prägnant
formuliert und er zeigt uns die probleme
die mit dem qualitätsbegriff
zusammenhängen natürlich wird er stark
von david hume einfluss zahlen der
regierung ist ja ein schottischer
philosoph aber auf der insel hat er
einen sehr hohen einfluss gehabt und
jetzt wollen wir uns fragen liefern nach
was soll der qualitätsbegriff
problematisch ist wenn wir versucht den
qualitätsbegriff zu ersetzen und
inwiefern russells these überzeugend ist
also diese ganzen versuche den
qualitätsbegriff zu problematisieren
stehen natürlich in der tradition von
david hume es gibt wahrscheinlich keinen
anderen philosophen behauptet jetzt mal
der so sehr den qualitätsbegriff
kritisiert hat und auch so wirkmächtig
war nicht nur immanuel kant den wir ja
in der letzten sitzung bei der
vorletzten sitzung
unsere vor vorletzten sitzung besprochen
hatten auch albert einstein sofern er
denn ein philosoph ist ich gebe ja
diesem semester noch ein seminar zum
thema was ist zeit und da ist also
albert einstein sehr sehr prominent und
albert einstein hat selbst von sich
gesagt er hat david hume gelesen und er
fand der fand david holmes theorie viel
ein leuchtender viel scharfsinniger als
diejenige von man erkannt als er hat
david hume gelesen und der vorteil von
itunes theorie ist einfach der dass er
dass diese theorie noch stärker mit den
methoden der modernen naturwissenschaft
zusammenhängt aber eben sehr stark
empirismus seine theorie zugrunde legt
und das macht kann auch immanuel kant in
einer gewissen weise aber eben durch
seine transzendentale philosophie wird
der qualitätsbegriff nicht in der natur
vor ort sondern eben in unserem trans
zentrale subjektivität und unsere
verstandes begriffe und deswegen fand
auch albert einstein kant nicht ganz so
spannend wie er fand dass es gibt so ein
paar aussagen von ihm
falls sie das interessiert können sie
sich die aufzeichnung der letzten
sitzung meines zeit seminars oder meines
die vorletzte sitzung auf meinem
youtube-kanal philo ist natürlich noch
mal zu gemüte führen
ich schreibe es noch mal hin viel
lowcost und ich bin ziemlich stolz dass
ich seit der letzten woche 500
abonnenten habe dieses kreises ist also
auf
und in diesem in diesem moment wenn sie
denn jetzt die aufnahme der heutigen
sitzung nach wien wird auch oben im eck
ein link erscheint wo sie also drauf
klicken können
und dann kommen sie zu dieser
aufzeichnung der sitzung des letzten
zeit seminars die moderne technik
macht's möglich
alles ist natürlich einen bescheidenen
maßstäbe aber für einen einfachen
universitätsdozenten mich ist oder nicht
ganz erfreulichen also wenn man anfangen
soll
denn jetzt wollen wir heute versuchen
diesen text sehr gut analysieren damit
flog ist noch weitere abonnenten
bekommen zieht das ziel muss lauten 1000
und die 1000 menschen erreicht werden
bis juni nächsten jahres genau auf
facebook sind wir natürlich auch und
twitter auch überall so beschreiben sie
mir jetzt bis juni nächsten jahres 1000
gereicht
vielleicht schaffe die 2000 ende
nächsten jahr aber das ist vielleicht
noch zu notorischen da müssen wir noch
ein bisschen mehr inhalt und mehr
effekte bieten so also jetzt haben wir
gleich wie es für die engländer oder für
die angelsächsischen philosophen typisch
ist
die reden nicht lange um den heißen brei
herum sind die kommen gleich zur sache
und so auch in diesem fall hier bei den
philosophen er sagt also wenn following
page first to mend handed calls ist so
ein krieg city bound abpfiff des leading
association dass wir ihn aufgeben müssen
sagt das ist also das problem und er
sagt hier am ende noch das der
qualitätsbegriff mit so vielen
fehlerhaften assoziationen verbunden ist
dass kakao man begriffe zu finden
wie der der kausalität
so kann sie es lesen also es geht hier
verschiedene dinge einmal um das gesetz
der kausalität
das war sehr sich bei qantas war der
grundsatz das war die zweite analogie
der erfahrung das ist das gesetz der
kausalität also möchte ich eben diese
ganzen prinzipien die mit dem
qualitätsbegriff zusammenhänge in frage
stellen und erstmalig war sommer
zusammen sind es die miss li ting
association die den begriff anrüchig
werden lassen ein vokabular daneben
betrifft dass das gesetz der kausalität
und daneben auch noch am schluss möchte
ich auch noch fragen aufwerfen die die
theologie betreffend wenn sie den
aufsatz ganz gelesen haben sehen sie
dass er am schluss auch noch auf die
frage nach der willensfreiheit ein geht
also willen zweiter und determinismus
das hatten wir hier auch kurz gesehen
diesem sinn wo wir dann ganz kurz noch
auf immanuel kants theorie der
kausalität aus freiheit zu sprechen kann
aus freiheit hier stellte sich die frage
wie dieser begriff der kausalität aus
freiheit wieder mit der kausalität der
natur wie er damit zusammenhängen also
wir reden in den meisten fällen in
diesem seminar wenn von kausalität reden
dann nur von kausalität der natur also
hier aber natürlich müssen wir
zugestehen müssen wir wenn wir einen
vollständig griff und kausalität haben
berührt dieser begriff auch unsere
fähigkeit zu handeln
unsere freiheit hat also wie wir eben
frei handeln können sofern handeln auch
eine form einer ausübung von kausalität
ist ein vorgang von qualität ist wie
dieser qualitäts vorgang mit den
naturgesetzen mit diesem gesetz der
kausalität in verbindung stehen wir
haben jetzt gesehen in der letzten
sitzung bei arthur schopenhauer dass er
versucht hatte den qualitätsbegriff noch
mal tiefer zu fassen wie diese wurzel
des zureichend grunde also kausalität so
wie wir sie jetzt zum beispiel in der
natur oder in der freiheit finden sind
nach schopenhauer nur zwei triebe
sozusagen zwei adern dieser wurzel
also man kann sie jetzt fragen ist
dieses kausalität gesetz so es denn gibt
ist das noch mal tiefer fundiert in
einem satz von zu einem grunde als wie
verhält sich der satz von zu einem
kunden zum gesetz der qualität ist
dasselbe
schopenhauer wird sagen nein die meisten
setzen es gleich bei leibnitz gibt es
den satz des zu reichen grundes auch
beim als solchen also das wollen wir
auch hier im auge behalten und jetzt wie
es das will ich jetzt ganz spannend bei
wasser er geht erst mal vom allgemeinen
verständnis der qualität außen hat also
wie wir reden wir gewöhnlich drüber das
ist auch so ein bisschen dieser
englische zog des common sense also wie
wird der begriff der philosophische
alltag verwendet und davon gehen wir aus
wir setzen jetzt nicht der ganz hoch
schwierig haben wir beginnen war von
wurzeln und jetzt sagte jetzt hat er
baldwins dictionary konsultiert
expectations for the following you can
karten youtube youtube inkompatibel
definitions also erstens casetti es gibt
also eine definition sagt folgendes
necessary connection auf events in the
times hieß also die notwendige
verbindung von ereignissen oder
ereignissen in der zeitreihe dann zwei
motion of may be included in the ford
press section of process is taking place
und konsequent auf anna bronze
und dann gibt es eine dritte definition
pausen effekt kann den effekt abkommen
relativ törns die not ist angry bird
sings face oder aspects of reality dafür
ist dieses tricks ist ein second car
center systems immediately after
entweder das second camps unterwegs ist
es das system i die before und
wasser wird jetzt sagen von diesen drei
definitionen sind nur zwei wirklich
sinnvoll zu verwenden bzw eigentlich
wenn sie sich vor allem diese dritten
definition zu aber jetzt schauen wir uns
nochmal die definition unabhängig von
rasse als interpretation an
auch jetzt mit blick auf die frage nach
der ontologie der regatta
also wir müssen jetzt über jetzt wird's
nämlich wieder analytisch also bei der
jugend war ja die frage nach der
ontologie der regatta also viel lowcost
mache jetzt mal weg hier also wir haben
hier steht in relation to be a es sei
jetzt mal die ursache sei die wirkung
jetzt können wir uns eben wie ich ganz
zu beginn unserer sitzung sagte also
seminars sagte wir können jetzt diese
relation und theologisch betrachten also
aus der frage der perspektive
was existiert das wird wird dabei als
existenz vorausgesetzt und wir können es
auch logisch betrachten logisch heißt
welche verhältnisse in welchen
verhältnissen stehen die dinge von dem
wir ökologisch reden können jetzt geht
man noch mal hier kurz und theologie ein
also da oder b wir haben lange darüber
geredet können ganz verschiedene dinge
sein es können erst mal dinge wirklich
sein nämlich wie kant in meinen augen zu
argumentieren scheint es könnten
substanzen seien mit kräften
also kann spricht davon dass ich in ein
account einem kausalen prozess die aktie
denn ziehen einen substanz ändern
so spricht er also er redet fast schon
so ein bisschen von dingen und und
kräften im sinne dieser rat hat dann
gibt es natürlich den klassischen fall
und der ist jetzt auch in der ersten
definition enthalten nämlich hier sehen
sie also hier events also es gibt
ereignisse das ist die häufigste der hat
ja das ist der beliebteste kandidat in
der anthologie von kennzahlen renata und
es gibt natürlich auch noch ein kandidat
der mir besonders besonders sehr gut
gefällt das ist der kandidat der
situation also eine situation verursacht
eine situation b weil da haben wir dann
nicht nur ein ereignis ist dann wir
haben so einen kontext wir haben eine
gewisse grenze stellen wir das immer
sofort wir haben dann hier so oder hier
so was
und das geht dann hier so über das ist
also alles situation und die führte zu
der nächsten situation derzeit das war
dann hat man irgendwie schöne
verhältnisse man hat also verhältnisse
die einfach innerhalb dieser situation
gibt es natürlich verschiedene
verhältnisse also ich mach mal das
einfach mal mit action irgendwie so aber
irgendwie sind diese verhältnisse einer
situation aufeinander abgestimmte sind
abgegrenzt und die führen dann in der
gesamtheit zur nächsten situation da
hätte man auch dieses zeitproblem nicht
mehr so stark präsent also hätte damit
einiges gelöst natürlich kann man sich
fragen was welche art von dinge sind
jetzt situationen situation sind
wahrscheinlich tatsache genauer gesagt
müsste man sagen sachverhalt genauer
noch genaue sachlage so muss man das
sagen also sachlagen sind häufig werden
häufig zu verstanden als komplexe
sachverhalte oder komplexe tatsachen
also es sind sachlage die lage ist so
sind also sehr komplexe konstellationen
von ereignissen die dann eben etwas
neues hervorbringen etwas anderes
bewirken
ok jetzt haben wir also mal hier die die
das ereignis als unter logischen
kandidaten für die regatta und wenn wir
jetzt noch mal auf die logik scheint
dieses dieser relation dann hatten wir
jetzt noch einen weiteren punkt in der
einer der letzten sitzung hier gehört
nämlich dass es sich hierbei um eine
asymmetrische revolution handelt das
heißt dass die ursache von b ist nicht
gilt das b auch die ursache von a ist
das also eine asymmetrische eine
asymmetrie anders ist es zum beispiel
falle der identität wenn a mit b
identisch ist
dann ist auch b mit identisch dann
können wir das also umdrehen
das ist also bei der causa ich hätte
nicht der fall und wir haben noch einen
weiteren kandidaten den wir hier
anführen können dir manchmal als
wahrscheinlich angenommen wird nämlich
den der transit ivi tät hat das hat
viele das kausalität transit eve ist
positiv gibt es das problem der kausalen
ausdünnung als wenn sie die kausalität
scattet ist natürlich wieder eine
metapher wenn sie die kausalität kette
nur lang genug machen dann bleibt am
ende nicht mehr viel übrig erkennbarkeit
der ursprünglichen ursache
dann können sich sozusagen situationen
gebildet haben die ich mache es mal so
dann haben wir hier die eigentlich die
ganze kausalkette durchlaufen durch die
zeit aber dann bilden sich in der
kausalkette bestimmte verursachung
folgen als situation heraus dann haben
wir praktisch also müssen sie das
vorstellen wir haben dann hier zumal in
dieser situation 1 sah die situation
zwei solche situation 3 haben wir dann
sagen wir 20 kausalität glieder in der
situation 1 die innen sich irgendwie
eine situation bilden die
zusammengenommen situation bilden
das geht natürlich durch die causa die
glieder reichen sich die hand durch in
der qualitäts kette aber dann sieht man
wird sich nach dem zwanzigsten beginnt
s21 lied und so geredet und dann bis zum
vierzigsten zb 7 hoppla das eine neue
situation
also war es wäre auch möglich dass also
wir dann am ende gar nicht mehr richtig
sagen können ja das hier ist jetzt also
nur eins das sei die ursprüngliche
ursache und das ist jetzt hier un die
die wirkung wirkung dass wir sagen
können diese erste ursache das erste
ereignis ist jetzt in die ursache dieser
wirkung im schluss zurück können dann
eigentlich nur noch so reden
es gab verschiedene situationen die
aufeinander ab gefolgt sind und wir
können eigentlich gar nicht mehr
die abschließende wirkung die wir da
reichen von der ich auch mal so sprach
dass sie jetzt sind 300 jahren sein
könnte und dass sie sich auf einen ganz
anderen planeten stadt dass sie auf
einem ganz anderen planet stattfinden
könnte
die können wir dann unter umständen gar
nicht mehr zurück führen auf die
ursachen würden sagen zu sagen dass
diese dieses ereignis hier dass das die
ursache von etwas wahr was viele hundert
jahre später stattfand an einem ganz
anderen ort das ist irgendwie konnte
und das kann man sagen
wir haben
da zu sein
der effekt ist
ja ich hatte jetzt diese identität
verletzung gar nicht mit blick auf die
kausalität relation als gebracht jetzt
als ein moment der kausalität relation
nur um zu veranschaulichen dass eben es
auch symmetrische oder reflexive
relationen gibt also bei identität wäre
es eben so dass wir von einer symmetrie
sprechen können dass eben die zweirad
austauschbar sind wenn er identität
gesagt und das geht eben bei kausalität
nicht da können wir eben nicht sagen
dass wenn die ursache ist von b das bier
auch die ursache ist von a ich würde
auch von identität nicht im sinne von
verursachung sprechen also die
identitäts relationen würde ich jetzt
auch nicht als ursache ursächlichkeit
relation verstehen einfach nur als ja
also eben identität und da können wir
dann die regatta umdrehen im falle der
identität
es gibt natürlich noch viele weitere
logische kategorien dann gibt's noch so
was wie das vieh reflexivität und so
weiter aber ich möchte jetzt auf die
ganzen anderen logischen dimension gar
nicht eingehen also sie sehen eben es
ist ein riesenproblem wie wir ebenso
eine kausalkette verstehen und das nennt
man dann wenn man sagt es ist transit
eve also das eben sich sagt die
ursächlichkeit durchhält dass die
durchgereicht wird wie beim domino stein
wo der erste umstoßen stein letztendlich
die ursache von allen weiteren ist dass
wir zurück führen können das scheint
sich in der wirklichkeit so zu verhalten
dass die kausale kraft einmal so
sprechen kann dass die einfach
ausgedünnt wird am ende aber immer viel
von der ursprünglichen ursächlichen
kraft drin dann ist einfach zuviel
strecke zu viel zeit vergangen
man kann jetzt mit der wii die jungs
sagen unsere assoziations gesetze werden
hier einfach
sozusagen enttäuscht oder unsere
assoziation gesetze greifen nicht mehr
weil der videos sagte und das sehr
plausibel um von ursachen wirkungen zu
sprechen
es muss raum zeitliche kontinuität
gegeben sein also es muss sehr nah
aneinander sein und das haben wir eben
bei ganz langen kausalketten unter
umständen nicht mehr
es kann einen ganz anderen ort geschehen
und auch für spät und dann sind wir auch
psychologisch unfalls nicht mehr in so
einer haltung dass wir es erwarten
würden also das sind noch mal so ein
paar sachen also die notwendige
verbindung von ereignissen in der in der
natürlich kann man jetzt auch hier bei
der ersten definition sich fragen ja
notwendige verbot für die verbindung was
heißt das eigentlich ja derzeit die
zweite definition sagt dann russell die
ist nicht so da kann man eigentlich
ziemlich schnell springen die ist wenn
nicht so wichtig ab jetzt eben die
dritte definition also ursache und
wirkung sind ko relativ begriffe die
zwei verschiedene oder von sich
unterschiedliche dinge bedeuten dinge
phasen oder aspekte dass andere
interessante dinge
dinge phasen oder aspekte der realität
also das ist jetzt wieder die ontologie
auf diese eingehen
die so miteinander verbunden sind das
wann immer das erste aufhört zu
existieren
das zweite also die wirkung eintritt und
zwar oben war danach und wann immer die
das zweite die also die wirkung eintritt
die erste unmittelbar zuvor aufgehört
hat zu existieren
ja das ist natürlich jetzt auch eine
sehr problematische definition aber hier
haben wir jetzt jedenfalls schon ein
bisschen was in der anthologie ein
bisschen genaueres also dinge phasen
oder aspekte sehr gut wie kann ein
aspekt von realität wie kann der dauern
wie kann der die wirklichkeit treten das
natürlich so nicht fragen jetzt schauen
wir wie russell die ganzen sachen
interpretiert also sagte also das kann
jeder die ssri definitions interne first
ob mosley ist an intelligence auto des
indischen offene analyse günstigsten
ihre gifte following this is it is true
that would be true an der ortsgrenze
something worden blut komponist in der
concept takes place ja alles hängt ganz
steuern mit der notwendigkeit wie wir
notwendigkeit verstehen wir hatten bei
der wm gesehen dass der qualitäts
relation so etwas nötig endes ins spiel
kommt also es ist nicht nur einfach so
dass kausalität so verstanden wird dass
wenn a dann werden immer wenn adam b
sondern es muss auch sein dass weil aber
das irgendwie
b notwendig macht also sein er zwingt
gewissermaßen und dieses erzwingen de
das ist eben in der bloßen regula riet
von ereignissen noch nicht gegeben
also erzwingen schließt regula ried 1
aber regula ried eigentlich noch nicht
das erzwingen
von 2 und das ist so was was was ihm
einfach gefehlt hat und dieser zwang
diese notwendigkeit also diese strikte
notwendigkeit dass es so sein muss dass
wenn die ursache dass die wirkung
eintritt das konnte natürlich david hume
nicht in der natur erfahrung finden die
natur sagt uns nicht dass etwas so sein
muss
wir finden natur keine wirkliche
nötigung unseren perzeption befinden
eben immer nur regula riten bestenfalls
regula rieten die aber auch in der
zukunft als ich sagen induktions schluss
handelt über den haufen geworfen werden
könnten also es gibt so was wie strenge
naturgesetze ist ein riesenproblem
auch die naturwissenschaften ok als es
hängt eine notwendigkeit
jetzt sagt er folgendes den ocean of
chaos ist so innovativ
also ja wie viele analytiker sagt jetzt
hier wasser das einfach die begriffe
nicht genau genug definiert sind
dass das problem da sagt natürlich auch
david hume es ist immer eine frage wie
wir die sache definiert von
notwendigkeit reden wir ganz schnell und
häufig auch einem sehr alltäglichen sinn
also daran hängt jetzt und jetzt
kritisierte eben
diese ganzen begriffe von notwendigkeit
das kann man es eigentlich zu
überspringen
und jetzt geht er hier ein also dass er
ihm ins wurdest du an der kompetenz ist
denn es ist mental ist es dass wir
spiele to the following definition es
ist ein prädikat of professional
function mini jet ist schoss robert auf
jetzt gewinnt argument er versucht jetzt
hier eben notwendigkeit oder das das
prädikat notwendig als eine funktion
darzustellen
die eben für die verschiedene werte oder
instanzen als argumente in frage kommen
jetzt eben eine mögliche definition wie
stehen sie zu dieser definition ja
in zwei bis jetzt behauptet dass
gerichte haben und eine bestimmte waren
in dem fall
funktion
position das alles ist also ich das
überhaupt ich manchmal
und ich sage das also wenn man die
kamera sagen dass china ware kann bei
falsch einigen besteht bisher
unbeeinträchtigt von allen möglichen asp
es uns also das system der welt
ja auch nicht ändern
was
wer ist ein guter punkt also ich würd
sagen wir lesen erst noch weiter und
schauen dann mal ob es das noch weiter
auf klingt er versucht jetzt am anfang
erstmal verschiedene definitionen zu
bringen das ist eben seine strategie
ist es auf seite vielleicht lesen uns
noch mal gemeinsam ist es auf seite zwei
folgen habe ich es ihr traum
naja
bisher war es das hier dieses hier
genau vielleicht schreibt das mal hin
ich habe zwar ein bisschen klarer
[Musik]
wir haben das gebraucht
das geht in deckung war es uns ein
kämpfer haben sozusagen und kann
trotzdem meine methode ist ein
gegenbeispiel wurde das erste
gruppenstunde nicht wohl warten als auch
des symbolismus und ein
wir können doch jetzt mal versuchen
diesen diesen satz hier mal zu
formalisieren
also sie können jetzt wir können sehr
praktisch das ganze mal formalisieren
also für alle iks wie machen wir das
jetzt haben sie ein vorschlag bin ich's
ein mann ist ein mensch ist wie wollen
wir das jetzt hier formalisieren
felix wenn nix ein mensch ist jetzt
praktisch quantifizieren
wir können jetzt die klammer aufmachen
oder ich glaube hier muss man jetzt so
machen dann sterblich
das ist jetzt praktisch für zwei mal im
also sagen wir mal so
[Musik]
und es wäre jetzt nach seiner definition
notwendig wenn es eben für alle
eingesetzten fix gilt
[Musik]
max
und jetzt mal das problem was jetzt
genau das problem
ja das ist wahr
diese kontingente wenn die kontingente
wahrheit zu
eltern aber also würde ich mal sagen es
gibt auch proposition zum beispiel wenn
adam die silberne musste weiß der
aussage ist
können alles eigentlich aus uns ist und
es aber trotzdem wahr und eigenständig
heißt ob bei einer veränderung von einem
umständen bleibt es trotzdem war und das
scheinen weder andere funktionen von
proposition und ich selbst mir von
diesem bis zum geht es uns ja ist also
genau in diese welt laden geöffnet und
die außen vor zu lassen
ist ein guter punkt die frage ist halt
natürlich wie wir zu solchen proposition
ahlen aussagen dann kommen diesen
konditionen sich schließen also auch
systemischen navidi wie die eben
gerechtfertigt werden können aber ich
meine prinzipiell logisch wäre es
möglich dass es sowas gibt ließ sie den
punkt schon
ja wir müssen es vielleicht erstmal
offen lassen und schauen ob er noch mal
dann eher darauf zu sprechen kommt und
inwiefern so dieses problem hier dieser
notwendigkeit für seinen weiteren gang
des der argumentation problematisch
werden kann ja und jetzt kommt eben
dieses nächster zeit seite 3 unten und
wo er jetzt eben auch sagt an
fortschrittlicher der definition des
participations can be true das ist ja so
wisst ihr diese position sketches
functions can be true and circumstances
hanson definition assistent ist nonsens
wortes menschen mit demenz ist die
argumentation folgten ss erschossen
jetzt haben wir nochmal dieses argument
hier oder dieser diese dieser satz wir
können hier für das ist natürlich alles
mögliche einsetzen sokrates oder platow
und so weiter und so fort das drückt
diese diese logische funktion aus dieser
notwendigkeit jetzt ist natürlich die
frage ob man kausalität mit ihrer
notwendigkeit so darstellen kann dass
man es als ein kollektion umfasst das
ist immer die ganz große frage ob das
also wirklich hinreicht um diese
notwendigkeit die in der kausalität
relation angelegt ist zu formalisieren
und viele darauffolgende denker haben
gesagt dass wir es nicht nur mit seinem
konditionen machen kann also wenn adam g
das liegt erstmal ja auf der hand dass
man sagt die eine ursache ist dann
ursache von einer wirkung wenn gilt das
wenn dann wie eine person konditionen
und zum beispiel hat ein anderer
erneuerer philosoph mit dem namen mecki
der auf den wir noch zu sprechen kommen
werden der hat eben gerade gesagt wir
müssen die modellierung die logische
modellierung der kausalität relation
noch viel komplex erfassen also nicht
nur durch durch hinreichende bedingungen
zu sagen sondern auch durch nicht
notwendige bedingung und durch nicht
hinreichend da kommen noch viel weitere
klammern drumherum als wird eine viel
längere viel engere konjunktion dann bei
mac i kommt dann noch eine bedingung
davor sie haben dann so ein ganz langes
bedingung ist schlecht für das dann gilt
dass es ursächlichkeit ausdrücken das
ist jetzt noch eine sehr rudimentäre
form notwendigkeit darzustellen
das wollte auch wollte ich es immer noch
hinweisen also es wird noch viel
komplizierter wenn wir die qualitäts
relation logisch formalisieren wollen
die zwar zur zweiten definition sagt der
folgenden secondaire finnischen
it-konzerns bieterprozess taking place
inkonsequenz rafa nadal hier zurück als
er sagt jetzt hier zu diesem zu diesem
zweiten dieser zweiten definition hier
[Musik]
in konsequenz oder infolge eines anderen
prozesses ist natürlich in der
konsequenz ist natürlich schon die
kausalität angelegten verklagen
man kann jetzt aber natürlich auch sagen
nun gut konsequenz fast wir jetzt mal
ein bisschen wörtlich also wir können
sagen konsequenz bedeutet einfach nur es
folgt darauf regelmäßig dann hätten wir
die kausalität die notwendige relation
noch nicht voll zugrunde gelegt aber wie
david hume gesagt hatte wir brauchen
eigentlich um kausalität zu verstehen so
eine art von notwendige bedingung
notwendige verknüpfung von beiden da
sagt er die brauchen uns nicht lange zu
kümmern diese
2 die definition und jetzt gehts eben
eben um die dritte definition und die
sagt er ist die die wichtigste
definition ist bei farmers presence in
die tests klären lässt leafs nothing to
design bei der great difficulty ist beim
tempo continuity auf korrekte definition
als note instant on content konnte das
sind the times ist kompetenz eines audi
effekt postmaster definition is correct
at time in the world of the world
contact in der finnischen kennt also das
problem ist dass beträgt jetzt wieder
die frage nach dem situationen also wenn
jetzt offensichtlich ursachen und
wirkungen hier gehen wir noch mal zurück
zur definition wie sie es sagt
phasen sind wenn sie also phasen sind
dann müssen sie zeitlich ausgedehnt
gedacht werden dann hätten wir also hier
eine phase und es wäre eigentlich fast
so eine situation nun also nicht genau
aber es wäre so ein bisschen
gegenrichtung situation
ich mach mal machen ein bisschen
deutlicher wir haben hier das jetzt mal
p1 ist die phase 1 und die führt zu
einer phase 2
und das sagen hier hier in diesem diesem
berührungspunkt da liegt dann
letztendlich der kausalität übergang und
jetzt sagt was sagt wasser was ist jetzt
das problem wenn wir uns qualität als
übergang von phasen die seien zeitlich
aufeinander folgen vorstellen was ist
das problem
ja
das ist also ein bisschen prozess ist
auch schon wieder
genau genau wie genau sie haben recht es
ist wohl besser wenn wir diese phasen
nicht als situation beschreiben sind als
ein prozess also ich glaube diese dritte
definition würde und logisch davon
ausgehen dass ursachen und wirkungen
prozesses ziehen und nicht situationen
herr situationen und prozesse sind ja
nicht das erinnern und situation sind
ihr konstellation würde ich sagen also
oder auch potenziale
während prozesse eben ganz klar
ausgedehnte dinge sind als ich stelle
mir immer sofort situation kann
sozusagen auch zum zeitlichen zeitpunkt
seien in dem eben bestimmte faktoren
gelten
ich weiß nicht wie sie die situation
vorstellen das sind umstände sind
kontext eine situation ist nicht
zeitlich ausgedehnt und unbedingt eine
situation ist zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt die konstellation dieser
umstand diese sachlage und ein prozess
und ich glaube deswegen haben sie zu
recht darauf hingewiesen eine phase wäre
er als prozess zu verstehen werden und
jetzt sagen sie ganz zu recht denn wenn
wir die alten prozess verstehen heißt es
dass wir hier unsere ketten in sich
schon haben vielleicht jetzt nicht so
viele aber so ein paar kausalketten
haben wir natürlich und das wir
eigentlich wenn wir jetzt hier auf den
übergang schauen müssten eigentlich nur
die letten letzten kaust die letzten die
das letzte kettenglied der ersten phase
in betracht ziehen dürften und dann
eigentlich nur das erste kettenglied der
zweiten phase wäre eigentlich die
ursachen der letzte kettenglied punkt
dieser phase jetzt hatten sich aber zwei
weitere kommilitonen gemeldet ja
haben
einzelne bausteine
tatsächlich zeichnet ist das kann sehr
das hier ist eine fahrt außerhalb
sondern
das ist spannend genau ob es eben zb
kausalitäten gibt oder ursachen gibt die
zeitlich ausgedehnt sind so dass man
sagt also so war wohl die vorstellung
dieser definition wenn ich es nicht
verstehe dass die phase p1 nur eine
wirkung eine ursache ist also die ganze
ursächlichkeit und dann sagt jetzt aber
was sofern die phase ausgedient ist muss
sie sich eigentlich wieder zerlegen
lassen in kausalketten aber das ist die
spannende frage ob sie das muss zwei
spiele situation die situation hat auch
eine gewisse ausdehnung
ich würde sagen mich unbedingt zeitlich
kann zeitlich seien aber eine situation
würde man zum beispiel sagen dass die
situation als ganze die ursächlichkeit
in sich schließt
oder würden sie sagen dass eine
situation sich wie eine phase weiter
aufspalten ließe in verschiedene ursache
wirkungs kettenglieder mir scheint dass
diese rede von unfallsituationen diese
aufspaltung wie sich bei der rede von
phasen gibt es ein bisschen vermeiden
kann weil man in der situation stärkere
kausale einheit schon voraussetzt ich
weiß nicht wie ihr sprachgebrauch hier
ist ja
genau
auch mehrere
ja genau ich glaube auch eine situation
wäre ihr sowas hier also ein querschnitt
vergehen natürlich bestimmte faktoren
hier ein mann ist kann er sich auf diese
verhältnisse an hier und bei einer phase
wäre halt die frage ob es hier nicht
doch um diese ausgedehnt hat geht
die behauptung das konzept nichts
anderes ist als das 2 ausgeglichen
haben also es gibt da kein ski ist und
ich glaube es werden
ein bisschen jetzt schon zu sagen
[Musik]
das sind spannende frage die mich auch
vor dem hintergrund meiner beschäftigen
mit der zeit interessiert ich habe diese
zeit seminar bei derzeit ist es so dass
kommt immer das argument von aquinos
oder eine ganze philosophen auch schon
der antike das oder auch schon bei
aristoteles findet sich dass das werden
wir sagen die gegenwart ist ausgedehnt
dass wir dann eigentlich ein widerspruch
überhaupt also die gegenwart kann
eigentlich gar nicht ausgedient sein
weil wenn sie ausgedient wäre dann
hätten wir eben wieder zwei komponenten
die eben vergangenheit zur hälfte
vergangenheit sind und zur hälfte
zukunft sind das ist klar als eine
zeitliche phase das wird schwierig die
also die gegenwart als als die gegenwart
kann nicht ausgedient sei die gegenwart
geht auf den nullpunkt
das ist das paradox der gegenwart
einerseits haben wir den eindruck wir
die gegenwart hat eine ausdehnung wir
sind jetzt im jetzt wir leben im jetzt
aber wenn man genau hinschauen können
kann die gegenwart eigentlich gar nicht
ausgedient seien als wird eben nur
wieder zerfallen zwei glieder zukunft
liedern vergangenheit schien jetzt ist
aber die frage ob eben aus der
zeitlichen auf spalt barkeit auch folgt
dass wir eine kausale aufspannt barkeit
annehmen müssen
das ist die spannende frage ob also es
nicht sein könnte
das pauschale verhältnisse wie zum
beispiel die ursache dass die mehrere
zeitpunkt umschließt das ist die
spannende frage also vorausgesetzt
scheint mir bei diesem argument dass
jeder zeitpunkt eigentlich eine ursache
sein könnte von etwas anderem
wie sehen sie es und das muss man ja
eine nicht sagen es könnte ja sein
eine ursache besteht eben aus fünf
zeitpunkten die ursache die umfasst
mengen theoretisch einfach 50 punkte
wenn man mal überhaupt von zeitpunkten
reden wollen hier
ich glaube dass ich sage wenn man die
definition der aufeinanderfolgenden
verhängt
dann muss das über zeit entschieden
aber wir können nicht
bei dem wird die zeit knapp
positiv das ist
schneider derzeit machen also es ist
genug nehmen
genau also das ist jedenfalls das
problem ich glaube das haben jetzt klar
gesehen also wenn wir von phasen
sprechen scheint es auch eine zu
implizieren dass diese phase in weiteren
qualitäts glieder zerfällt sofern sie
zeitlich ausgedehnt ist und jetzt sagt
er weiter in oder er biete
sie schreibt braucht er ja der gebracht
die qualität die wir haben
abgesehen von der frage der inhalte vor
wusste das schon musste schon kaufen
geben um die linken sind einfach zu weit
weg von bmw 2 hinter gitter keine
mittelbare berührungen braucht daher
vereine aus dem linken und dem rechten
funktioniert es so wäre würde ich auch
sagen dass hier eben schon transit er
impliziert ist macht er jetzt vielleicht
nicht explizit oder
[Musik]
und wenn die welt so benutzten irgendwie
seid dann wäre auch die konsumierte
aber nicht an dass man deswegen nicht
gleich bleibt man zusätzlich zu dem
hause 1 4
wenn sie uns noch mal hin dass des
falles mit ihm könnten
damit würde
ein gehalt wie brooke bestens aufgehoben
daraus das ist nicht gelungen genau an
so lesen wir mal weiter es gibt jetzt
noch eine hälfte weitere hälfte ich habe
jetzt so die hälfte gelesen es geht also
hier weiter geht es heute das kabinett
die minister die ration auf dem kossuth
limit ein halber much we may teammanager
devils thirring effekt zu den feind
relativ kurses von die ihre handykosten
changewave denn in der first place is to
be found in nature and in the second
place e10 strange things change to be
accepted inside of possibility that
existing play some time schutz hat die
explode hinter den effekt wenn it might
just as they have done that may have
gone und an change without radio sind
ins gefängnis da dämmert der voll ist
fährt unter view endeffekt can be
content scott konnte just in time in der
aks endeffekt etwas bittet bei einem
interview
es war es ist jung in die abba the
passion of the first definition gibt es
ja noch weitere informationen jetzt zu
diesem zu dieser zweiten hälfte
interessant finde ich jetzt hier diese
rede von der explosion das also der
grund oder die ursache nachdem sie vor
einiger zeit existiert hat plötzlich in
die wirkung explodiert
haben sie da noch weitere punkte die sie
aus diesem zitat nehmen ja
durch sein
ist natürlich ein bisschen die metapher
explodieren
wie es geht dann können
ja also wir sehen diese debatte um die
und theologie es geht es also um die und
logie auch der ursachen ob sie eben
jetzt ausgedient sind oder nicht die
führt uns zu tiefer liegenden
fragestellungen die die zeit anbelangt
also causa liegt die rede von kausalität
kann eigentlich gar nicht geschehen ohne
die rede von zeitlichkeit mit
einzuschließen
bei der wm hatten wir das auch gesehen
da hatte er gesagt also die ursache ist
vor der wirkung und sie kann ich
zugleich sein weil wir nämlich dann gar
keine zeit mehr hätten dann würde
nämlich alles letztendlich auf einen
punkt schrumpfen wenn kein zeit ich
hätte differenz zwischen ursache und
wirkung wäre dann könnten wir alle
kettenglieder letztendlich sagen auf
einen punkt schrumpfen lassen
wenn bull zeit zwischen ursachen rücken
ist gilt es natürlich auch für die
weiteren ursachen wirkungen einer ganzen
kette und dann schrumpft die sozusagen
zu sagen auf null
und das geht nicht qualität ist nach dem
medium immer zeitlich ausgedehnt haben
natürlich legt jetzt die rede von
zeitliche ausgedehnt heid von kausalen
übergängen nahe das ist sowas wie
kleinste punkte gibt das ist natürlich
über dieses problem was sich auch in der
mathematik und der physik vor allem
ergibt haben wir es hier mit einem
kontinuum zu tun
also gibt es praktisch immer kleinere
unendlich kleine phasen die wir immer
weiter analysieren können oder kommen
wir irgendwann mal auf so was wie
diskrete größen die einfach nicht mehr
weiter teilbar sind
ok jetzt geht es weiter und bieten
unser leben
hin
[Musik]
da gibt es auch eine riesen debatte
darum in das was die zeit anbelangt ob
die zeit eben diskret ist oder konnte
kontinuierlich ist wie man der physik
der modernen physik gibt es dann die
planck zeit die für sie geht davon aus
dass zeit gewandelt ist alles eben diese
diese kleinsten größen gibt aber in der
philosophie gibt's da alle möglichen
positionen dazu ich glaube das
augustinus er davon ausgeht dass eben es
keine zeit punkte gibt sind dass es eben
immer weiter differenziert ist zwar der
tiger ist das ist ein guter punkt also
die frage wie man zeit misst ist ja dies
ja also diese diese frage nach der zeit
taktung und zeitmessung die ist bei
aristoteles sehr prominent und
aristoteles rät daneben davon dass zeit
eine anzahl von bewegung ist also und da
ist dann das aristoteles richtet sich
offenbar nach den jahres abläufen und
tagesabläufen da ist dann aber die
prämisse inkludiert das eben diese
abläufe wie jahres abläufe dass die eben
genau gleich sind das jedes jahr genau
lange ist und das hat man eben
festgestellt am anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts das eben nicht jedes jahr
gleich ist sondern dass eben manches
linkes paradox aber es ist so wenn man
eben jahr als umlauf verstehen um die
sonne
dass wir eben dann feststellen dass man
die jahre ein paar tausendstel sekunden
länger oder kürzer da und das konnte man
erst anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
machen als die quarzuhr entwickelt
wurden dann könnte man das dann messen
zeit deswegen weil eben die auslenkung
der erde um die sonne manchmal ein paar
meter mehr ein paar meter weniger ist
das hängt halt von gravitationskräfte
abtreten von ganz komplexen
konstellationen und deswegen dauert die
manche jahre länger und manche kürzer
aber nur ganz minimal
das konnte man lange zeit gar nicht
messen und aristoteles stellst eben
voraus dass die ordnung des kosmos
perfekt getaktet ist das also jedes jahr
exakt gleich null
und dann kann er natürlich zeit auch
über w bewegung definieren weil die
bewegung der konstant ist aber das geht
jetzt eben nach der modernen physik
nicht mehr wir können nach der modernen
physik zeit nicht mehr durch bewegungs
taktung definieren wie wird denn die
sekunde gemessen die sekunde wird jetzt
gemessen durch strahlung durch
wellenlängen
da wird sie jetzt gemessen ja können sie
mal nachschauen auf wikipedia wie eine
sekunde definiert ist das irgendwie teil
einer
das zerfallsprozess und dann geht es um
die wellen von einem bestimmten einen
gewissen chemischen stoffen das ist eine
gute frage
genau ja ja ihr habt ja sie haben schon
recht
sie hatten sie haben schon recht sie
haben schon recht ist es dann eben nicht
mehr so eine globale oder so eine
universale bewegungsrichtung sondern ski
daneben sehen kleine ins in zeltlagern
[Musik]
schon aber wie eben als philosophin und
philosophen schon hat das ist eben
unterschied wie als philosophin und
philosophen wollen es eben schon dann
möglichst absolut auch wenn es sehr
schwierig ist und jetzt sagt er weiter
in diesem text los angeles same state of
the lost its way for the first of queens
definition dafür dass john stuart mill
cessation recognition of which remain
piller auch interaktiv scientist bei der
familie thurn varieté auf sächsischen is
found by observation and effect which
has präsident also natürlich wird jetzt
hier wieder ein brite bemüht um eben
diese qualitäts problematik zu klären da
sagte alle sind es die der hauptpfeiler
der induktiven wissenschaft
naja die in variabilität hatte die um
die praktisch die konstanz könnte man
auch sagen die konstanz der abfolge das
scheint jetzt ihr wieder so eine art von
regula reed stieß der kausalität zu
sagen da wird jetzt ein bisschen die
notwendigkeit wieder so ein bisschen
unterschlagen
hier haben die frage ist wie es da also
man könnte jetzt in dieser ihnen
variabilität da die notwendigkeit wieder
raus lesen verstehen sie das so man wenn
man sagt immer dass wir verstehen wie
regula ried verstehen wie regula riet
das inventar dann okay dann wenn wir das
dann so formulieren eben wenn dann liegt
hier eben also wenn es logisch
definieren dann liegt eben in diesem
konditionell schon so eine gewisse
notwendigkeit das ist dann schon was
stärker ist eben immer die frage wie man
diese in variabilität versteht ob man es
eben logisch fast dann haben wir das
dann haben wir diese notwendigkeit drin
dann ist es eine implikation irgendwie
immer als auch die frage inwiefern die
ursache die wirkung irgendwie in sich
schon schließt das ist dann wieder die
frage nach der identität
ob da auch eine art von identität
enthalten ist nicht haben wenn wir jetzt
aber halt wenn wir nur sagen ebenso ein
bisschen alltag sprachlich oder wie
david hume ist gesagt hatte wenn a und b
sondern so ein weiterer also weiteren
waren dann haben wir eben die
notwendigkeit nicht also ein bisschen
dieses problem wie man von dieser in
variabilität spricht
und jetzt stellt er sich eben die die
fragen die auch für uns immer zentral
sind aus systematischer perspektive also
er stellt sich jetzt die frage
seite 7 what is meant bayern im moment
und zweitens foul an menne dateimanager
wird die betriebe chaos um defekte sind
jetzt also spannende fragen und die mir
scheint sind das rein theologische
fragen erst mal also das sind jetzt noch
gar nicht so sehr logische fragen im
spiel also logische frage gut die frage
ist wenn ihr von notwendigkeit reden
notwendigkeit jetzt disziplin er
betrachtet ist so ein bisschen etwas was
in zwei bereichen angesiedelt ist als
einmal ist notwendigkeit klar eine
logische angelegenheiten notwendigkeit
kann aber dann auch als modalität
metaphysisch verstanden werden alle die
den begriff der notwendigkeit fällt in
meinen augen sowohl in die logik als
auch in die mitte rücken
okay wir sind jetzt die zwei fragen also
was ist ein ereignis und wie lange kann
derzeit zwischenraum zwischen ursache
und wirkung sein
und jetzt geht er zur ersten frage
er sagt an die wand in der statement auf
der long history is intended to be
something is likely to recover bekam
zivilen it follows the event erster
abartig oder bei familie börsen und der
make money instanz ist voll außer den
event was something of the state of the
universe sind sie das heil im moment ist
samtig likejacking match dropping ab
hänni ins lot of fun automatiken
maschinenbrand historiker ist türkis
truck is to be de temple university of
maine party time being instanz aufrecht
als jetzt haben wir eine ganz
interessante bestimmung des ereignisses
mir scheint ist das jetzt auch das erste
mal so in den von uns behandelten texten
dass dieses ereignis konkret bestimmt
hat das problem dass wir uns immer
gestellt hatten in den vorherigen
sitzung hatte
wenn wir von dem ereignis sprechen dann
sprechen wir dann von einem
individuellen ereignis also wenn etwas
singulären von einer singularität oder
sprechen wir von typen von konkreten
singularitäten und man kann es so machen
man kann sagen zb der typ ist oder
sollen das universale ist eben das
schreiben wir groß und das individuelle
ereignis das schreiben wir mit dem
kleinen es wird häufig sogar war und was
sagte jetzt eben über das ereignis wie
versteht jetzt jetzt russell ein
ereignis nach diesem typ groß
geschrieben und nach diesen zu klein
geschrieben
die sollen das ist sein
es ist alles offen
es gibt jedenfalls 212 verständnis
weißen von von ereignisse
genau als erstmal das muss erstmal
darstellt also sagt hier also definitiv
so ein bisschen als haben im sinne eines
beispiels ganz gut gefällt mir einen
penny fallen zu lassen oder reinzuwerfen
in seine maschine her also da sollten
sie da so rein reinzuwerfen und das muss
natürlich sich jetzt wiederholen lassen
also wenn wir von einem ereignis
sprechen dann muss es wiederholbar sein
und deswegen kann jetzt nicht in die
kausale analyse eingehen
zum beispiel eben die temperatur dieses
pennies also wenn die temperatur des
panels jetzt noch ein faktor wäre ein
kausaler faktor
dann könnten wir sozusagen nicht mehr
von einem typ sprechen also ein tipp
eines ereignisses wäre jetzt eben den
penny in die maschine werfen dann müsste
ich sagen ein müssten einen neuen typ
entwickeln
der typ des penis in die maschine werfen
wobei der penny die temperatur von
soundso viel grad celsius hat dann wäre
eben das weitere typ zu sagen
gutes argument
das gericht bezieht das gesetz gegen das
auch mal schiefgehen kann und dass diese
ungenauigkeit beschreiben das ist dass
man kauft die umsätze sprechen also ja
stimmt das thema denn der bereits als
argument gegen irgend wie
personenbeschreibung beendet
wir wollten einfach mal so ein bisschen
klar bekommen was unter ereignis
versteht weil das ist immer so ein
bisschen ambivalente von ereignissen
jetzt hatten sie sich noch mehr in
diesem jahr holen der physik dann weil
wir jetzt nicht gerade einmal um
einfache weg sondern
sozusagen schon versuchen das muss auch
sagen die liga holen und natürlich mag
sein dass ich garantiert
der eingang zu einem beobachter haben
wirklich ist
von bestimmten
mit großem elan sonst ist es ganz
natürlich haben keine aussage
weil ich habe mich von unten über die
geschehnisse und da kommt
ist auszuschließen
es ist aber sie sagen alles richtig erst
mal also es gibt wirklich dass probleme
müssen einerseits typisieren alle groß
machen um irgendwie so so generelle
aussagen auch tätigen zu können den wir
es logisch formalisieren müssen wir
typisieren da können wir natürlich nicht
vom in die wellen ausgehen auf der
anderen seite haben sie natürlich auch
recht das eben typisierungen immer auch
etwas ja abstraktionen sind und man sich
dann fragen muss inwiefern abstraktionen
nicht dann doch auch von kausalen
faktoren ab sehen das war ihr argument
und ob nicht dann eben auch so eine
menge angegeben werden muss also statt
dass man statt
dass man da er dann so eine menge an
gibt und dann hier eben verschiedene
faktoren mit einem ja also sage jetzt
mal 11 14 23
und dann kann ich sagen wenn ich nur
genau genug hinschaut findet ihr
unendlich viele faktoren die irgendwie
causa relevant sein könnten natürlich
das problem ist wie groß ist denn jetzt
hatten sie sich melden
daran haben dass es überhaupt dass ein
letztlich lag es ist nicht daheim war
eben gesetze ja wiederholbarkeit so ein
bisschen implizieren oder die den
betroffen
mit sicherheit nicht
er bringt
ja ich glaube das ist ein guter punkt
also dass man da unterscheiden muss also
eine faktische nicht wiederholbarkeit
oder eine prinzipielle nicht
wiederholbarkeit ja immer der oder die
frage wäre die dass man vielleicht von
zwei verschiedenen arten von gesetzen
spricht also ich mein ein gesetz was man
er lässt ist jetzt eben auch nicht so
ein gesetz wie unbedingt zu ein
logisches gesetz dass wenn art und b ist
ne da sich fragt was für eine art von
gesetz ist hier im spiel von was reden
wir welche art von gesetzen
es gibt bestimmt eine für alle art von
gesetz die eben voraussetzt dass es
vielleicht faktisch nur eine instanz
geben kann die diesem gesetz folgt aber
das ist eben prinzipiell oder der
möglichkeit nach viele beiträge geben
können müsste ich glaube so versteht er
eben gesetz und wenn es dann eben nur
eines gibt dann wäre das eben so ein
bisschen nach dieser definition des
gesetzes ein bisschen widersprüchlich
dann kann man sich von
und mit dem sächsischen oder
gründe übernommen
definitorischen vorausgesetzt wird das
sagen die beiden
selbst zu sprechen und zu sagen
hier zieht gleich dazu
ja
analoge
oder
vollends über 11
heute sagen
trotzdem wenn ich das leid führen würde
ich eigentlich
was können
meyer
die wahl
die wenigsten ich will nicht sagen wann
aber es sind noch mehr
gibt es 64 seiten
vielleicht in zukunft sein
finanzkrise und 2000
das ist es ja auch gesellschaftlich ist
ja kein knistern hören
da kann man sagen der welt schon dieses
gesetz ist einfach nicht passieren
in taiwan oder auch sagen dass mir das
gegen ich nicht und das unterscheidet
das trifft nicht das identische zu sagen
wir sprechen und ich hätte kommen können
statt eingesetzt entsprechendes nach
unterschiedliche dinge
[Musik]
ich glaube dass acht bewerben das ist
schon raus bitte noch mal dazu
von außen
[Musik]
weil er aus
von außen betrachtet
ein bisschen so einer anderen stehen
so fliegen zähler
august anzeigeneinnahmen dass man sich
zurecht
wir wissen es aber noch nicht
- und die arbeiten kosten viel geld
genau wissen was soll ich sagen
ganz mehrere meldung erst hierher
weil sind
die jungen gesamte schließt und
natürlich und da an setzte genau
irgendwie gesagt ist eigentlich das
inflationsproblem ist einfach zum
beispiel durch
die beweise
irgendwas
der ist noch hier
[Musik]
schreiben was ich würde die schuld über
also das kann doch nicht sein dass sie
gesucht haben damit startet
ursache ist oft behaupten sie stellen
nur so aber eingestellt und version
gefunden und dann so um die figuren also
zweiten service konzept bestimmt
aufgefüllt wird und dann gehts wohl
erkannt dass menschen oft nicht dem
konzert
und dann ist
die chance
und in
und jetzt
die systeme sind jedenfalls sehr
spannende fragen hier entsteht und wir
wollen jetzt gerade mal weitermachen
beim nächsten zitaten jetzt geht es um
die zeiten da war die erste frage war
jetzt eben was ist ein ereignis fast
einmal kurz zusammen als ein ereignis
ist die rede von ereignissen ist
ambivalent weil man erst mal wenn man
sagt dass ein ereignis davon geht das
etwas individuelles ist aber wenn man
dann das ereignis auf den begriff bringt
also wenn man von diesem vorfall als von
einem fall spricht sprechen möchte als
eine vorfall dann haben wir als fall
schon einige immer die generelle
kategorie angewendet also wir sagen das
war ein solcher vorfall ein vorfall oder
ein sachverhalt oder im juristischen ist
es ja noch viel extremer es war ein fall
haben sie ein fall
wir müssen sie diesen fall immer unter
einem gesetz bringen können sagt jetzt
mal so es wird summiert damit etwas ein
fall sein kann muss es subsumiert werden
können und das ist gerade eben diese
bewegung hier dass man sie unter einen
tisch bringt natürlich und das ist dann
die anreise wir das ereignis handhabbar
ist logisch modelliert weil es eben als
ein generelles ein genereller begriff
aufgefasst werden kann oder also einen
typus das problem ist eben damit dass
wir ganz entschieden abstrahierend von
individuellen vorkommnissen
bestandteilen die unter umständen kausal
relevant sein könnten das können kausale
faktoren sein wie zb irgendwelche
temperaturen oder sonstigen faktoren
vielleicht auch das metall des penis
dass er irgendwie aus dem anderen metall
es ist ein penny aber der penny aus dem
jahr 1970 wurde aus so ne metall
gestanzt und der penny als im jahr 2018
wurde aus so ne metall gestanzt ja oder
irgendwie die produktionsweise hat sich
verändert aber es ist dennoch ein penny
so was also da müssen wir abstrahieren
und dann komme halt so einen punkt und
die frage ist halt wie verhält sich das
zu diesen
weitere faktoren die von denen
absolviert wurde sind diese faktoren
nicht doch auch irgendwie causa relevant
und falls sie kausal relevant wären
müssen wir nichts anderes machen als sie
letztendlich wieder auf eine typisierte
form zu bringen nämlich daneben sagen
der penny des typs 1970 also präge jahr
1970 wenn das nicht reicht der penny
pregla 1970 temperatur in diesem bereich
dann hat man eben dann bekommt man am
ende ebenso eine ganze als praktisch
konjunktion also mit lauter uns und das
wird dann eben als ein typ gefasst also
mit diesem weiteren faktoren die ganzen
faktoren werden mit einer konjunktion
zusammen das ist also die spannende
frage
und das wollen wir einfach man muss
verstehen dass haben sie noch kurz zum
himmel
[Musik]
machen
die sorgen können
genauso gibt pragmatische interessen
nein die philosophen nichts
die philosophin und philosophen die
gehen immer weiter bis zur letzten
konsequenz bis zum bis zum letzten punkt
die frage ist ja dann immer dass es ja
die kausalität aus freiheit die wir bei
cannes kennengelernt haben gibt es einen
ersten anfang aller kausalketten und
kann würde sagen ja nämlich mit uns bei
uns in jeder freien handlung sind wir
selbst die ursachen die selbst keine
keine ursache mehr vor sich haben wir
sind also unbewegte bewegung so ein
bisschen dieser hinsicht werden wir uns
als freie vorstellen kann also sagen
richtig
also nochmal ruhe hinweis auf die
rechtswissenschaften die frage nach
kausalität ist möchte ich doch mal noch
mal sagen immer so ein bisschen normativ
aufgeladen also wir fragen warum es geht
uns da durchaus auch ein interesse und
besonders relevant wird die frage nach
ursachen wenn es eben hier unschuld geht
und ordnet zurechenbarkeit nicht nur
aber da wird die frage besonders
besonders relevant und sagten auch die
rechtswissenschaften die klammern manche
faktoren aus das sind 1 pragmatische
gründe
man könnte aber auch folgendes sagen die
rechtswissenschaften klammern deswegen
manche bedingungen aus weil sich da die
transit ivi tät der kausalität relation
so ausgedünnt hat dass diese faktoren
einfach keine rolle mehr spielen
sagen
ja
naja also in guter punkt jedenfalls
jetzt möchte ich noch mal den zweiten
punkt noch kurz vor lesen also die next
question konstante time in the lovers no
doubt think of course infektes kantiges
in time war bis vor reasons origin ist
impossible hands sind serrano infinity
ward timing devils der must be some
feinheit labs of time between the fact
that once races ins juridicum tsv aber
short wie medien in charitys something
that happened during des interviews
private expected results ipod touch
android market der ist ein earthquake
mit absetzte maschinen einmal
kalkulations in europa auf expected
effektiv entlastet der britischen
bekannt also wir können jetzt die
konjunktion machen von unendlich vielen
gliedern oder bedingungen das sind
bedingungen ja also ich muss praktisch
folgendes sagen also praktisch das sei
jetzt die ursache und dass die wirkung
also wenn du dann w und jetzt würde
grasser sagen wir müssen eigentlich die
ursache folgendermaßen bestimmen wir
müssen sagen wenn und b12 bedingung und
b2 und b3 praktisch
ganz genau ganz genau und wie 4 und so
fort das kann man hier auch nochmal noch
einmal ausklammern ob zum beispiel also
dass er einfach der gesamte kontext in
dem ein typus oder ja das ist
letztendlich läuft das dann eben wieder
nicht nur es läuft auf die ganzen
kontext heraus dann dann w also das sind
ist die argumentation
das geht so ein bisschen diese diese
faktoren rein aber sind einfach die die
randbedingungen die randbedingungen
können eben aufgrund auch der zeitliche
struktur die randbedingungen sind kausal
einfach relevant wir können sagt er wohl
oder jedenfalls dieser punkt wir können
nur schlecht abstrahieren wie es mir
stehen sie noch abschließend jetzt zu
diesem argument dass ein zu diesem punkt
die zeiten sind und zeigen
und ja deswegen nicht sind
das verändert
ja wie stehe ich wieder weitere
störungen zu diesem zitat hier
frauenfeld
ja wie steht sie noch weitere meinung
dazu selber bin überzeugt dass ich finde
es ein bisschen solistisch muss ich
sagen aber bitte
ärgerlich ist das was man
daraus folgt also man könnte sagen es
gibt eine qualität die ist nicht
regelmäßig die gemeinderechnung sprechen
zeigt profis zeigen welche wechsel
und diese tatsächlich passen in jede nur
vage beschreibungen des alltags nein zu
sagen
das passierte
die man sprechen die qualität mir fällt
noch eine sache ein also hier sagte wie
ein klo den bäumen
da würde ich einfach sagen können wir
nicht hier sagen wenn wir die moment
können wir nicht einfach sagen wie
ändern die und theologie von ereignissen
zur situationen und wir sagen einfach
das hier ist jetzt eine situation
wir packen alles rein natürlich also
sagen dass damit könnten wir so ein
bisschen begrifflich wie mir scheint
dieses problem des ereignisses weil mit
der mit dem griff der situation haben
wir eben begrifflich schon die ganzen
konz texte mit drin als die situation
ist so definiert dass eben alle umstände
sind die eine andere situation dabei
sind diese konstellationen diese ganzen
und ziehe diese ganzen konjunktion
glieder die fassen wir in eine situation
und also hier sondern haben jetzt ein
argument dafür gewonnen bei rasse von
ursachen nicht im sinne von ereignissen
zu sprechen oder von typen von
ereignissen sondern im sinne von typen
von situationen natürlich kann man sagen
die situationen sind in sich so
feinkörnig so komplex dass es gar keinen
typus einer bestimmten situation geben
kann weil jede situation singulär ist
dann wäre eben dann würde eben erst
nicht situation bedeuten sondern
singularität dann wird nämlich
schwieriger her aber sie wollten doch
was da zu sein
leichter
es wäre eine szenische frage
ja aber man hätte ihnen nicht mehr das
ereignis und die ganzen umstände in
einer konjunktion würde sagen wir packen
ja aber eben genau das ist unendlich
viele faktoren meinetwegen aber sie
fallen alle unter die situation also
sind alle betreffen alle situationen
wir haben es also wir haben's kompakter
würde ich sagen natürlich ist die frage
wie es der unter logische status eine
situation
was ist eine situation ist eine
situation zeitlich ausgedehnt muss nicht
sein wir haben ja gesagt na also es eine
zeit querschnitt ist ein querschnitt
durch die welt ein state of the art zu
sagen wird ein zustand
der richtig manchmal braucht man braucht
man braucht es gar nicht zeitlich so
genau spezifizieren wir sagen einfach
nur diese faktoren diese faktoren diese
konstellation und das sei die situation
aber da haben wir jetzt eben einen
starken ein starkes auto oder nieten
jedenfalls gewiss argument dafür nicht
mehr von ereignissen zu sprechen sondern
von situationen zu sprechen also jetzt
für die ontologie von uns von interesse
wir sind jetzt am ende der zeit
angelangt ich möchte das nächste mal das
gehen wir noch mal ein bisschen auf den
text ein ich meine wir haben jetzt hier
die wichtigsten punkte herausgearbeitet
aber es gibt noch ein paar punkte dass
er vielleicht noch am ende auf die frage
nach der willensfreiheit eingehen und
was er dann eben vorschlägt man muss
auch sagen rasters theorie ist heute
nicht mehr so akzeptiert also heute
würde man auch die naturwissenschaften
würden da sicherlich wasser nicht folgen
als man muss seine theorie durchaus
problematisiert aber wir haben durchaus
gesehen der kausalität begriffes
hochgradig problematisch und jetzt nicht
nur wie bei der wii team aus der
psychologischen fragestellungen heraus
sondern tatsächlich wie ich glaube dass
es wasser zeigt aus ökologischen
fragestellungen und logischen mir
scheint dass hier die ontologie fast
noch am stärksten ist bei kassel
mehr noch als es die logik ist aber
darüber kann das nächste mal noch
diskutieren dann bis in einer woche